so getting an officer of the law and a
gang Lord to travel into international
waters together wasn't a single time but
it's what happened mixed that crossed
every boundary possible that's a joint I
am no spokesperson for weed smoking but
it definitely fueled this form of unison
and celebration why was this such a
thrilling moment for me
what on earth brought us into
international waters with the most far
between group of individuals this seed
this non normal seed is the cause and
effect to all of this and if you
confuses to what the seed envelope is
that's totally cool I built this global
map which you can find are not normal
showed up where you plant a seed which
is an unfinished idea in your city each
week I choose a new suit
I fly to that city and competed with you
the sweet seed is by Tristan which says
together we should celebrate our
differences be South Africa good welcome
to my new weekly show not know boots of
this variety of Secrets this beautiful
action not what's which history
72 hours ago I arrived in Cape Town
South Africa from Tokyo South Africa is
very unstructured in comparison to Japan
as you arrive at the airport you drive
through the squatter camps which are the
informal segments of the city eventually
reaching this kind of first world
paradise being the most and sometimes
only part of Cape Town that the world is
shown it's not all like this though this
is just a fraction of it what is
actually happening behind the curtain in
South Africa does the youth believe in
its future and is it really what you
thinks it is it was amazing to see Gabi
again these constant creative
perspective shifts can be draining on my
mind and her calmness offers such a
blissful escape from what can often seem
perpetual chaos
[Music]
hello it was time to meet Tristan and
talk about his seed come on in there's
no milk
yeah this idea of celebrating your
differences that's what really intrigued
me harina she knows like fact it's
something so powerful there but where do
you like where is your mind at so for me
like kids honest this diverse vibrant
place with so many cultures that are
already segregated if that makes sense
but and I think that that's something
that needs to be showcase I don't think
that most people understand that in a
city bowl like Cape Town how many
different communities lie within that
let's go to Table Mountain on top of you
can catch a cable car and we can kind of
look at this viewpoints we can also
showcase it in a round way I've never
really looked at it like that
Tristan Smith is a 19 year old South
African wide kid whose parents and
siblings are all expats living across
the globe they have left for multiple
reasons but ultimately to live better
lives just and however doesn't want to
give up on Easter and ideally seeks
positive progression in what should be a
beautiful intertwined synergy of
cultures
we headed up Table Mountain which
usually gives you a 360 degree angle of
the city from above but the winter
morning mist wasn't working in our favor
okay I'm gonna have to show you case
what it looks like with my breakfast Bay
with you have the Table Mountain in the
middle here the European seventh ascend
known as tomboy stow the unworkable Cape
malaise in this NBS what's known as the
birth was curtain where most of the
African people live
this is kinda where a big part of the
quasi culture of understand see points
votre age old Jewish community Joey at
the southern suburbs which is mostly a
white suburban neighborhood and then
what's known as the Cape Flats very
dangerous and majorly gang run area
mostly a Muslim community to give you
context to the why South Africa
experienced the parties translating to a
partner's a system of institutionalized
racial segregation from 1948 until the
early 1990s apartheid enforced the
segregation of different racial groups
writing it into South African law it
severely disadvantaged the majority of
the population where most were kept just
above destitution because they were non
what having technically ended in 1994 a
quarter century later the majority of
the population still lives in relative
often geographically and socially
separated destitution without a means to
rise from it and well one could still
argue that South Africans could now go
where they please with whom they please
it is still a land of astonishing
waterful contrasts
I then took Tristan to my favourite
thinking spot the unfinished bridge
that's an example of an unfinished idea
it reminds me of what I call and finish
the listen from simple conversations to
huge ideas unfinished ilysm says with
meaningful applied creativity you can
always finish what you started
I thought I would take Tristan to a
restaurant in the area that's known as
dangerous or less savory it's not at all
dangerous in fact it has the best
barbecue in South Africa Bri this is by
far my favorite meat probably in the
world it's so the idea needs to be about
two people two completely different
people coming together and in that they
need to be maybe somewhat isolated from
everybody up
I can know his awk yeah you know what is
cool though is the idea of international
waters like is it's kind of like a free
fall well from what I know it's creating
the difference between maybe a civil
servant like a law a person that abides
by the law like policeman versus I don't
know prisoner that's a [ __ ] cool idea
international waters policeman a
prisoner break laws get them to break
laws on internet sort it would break the
hierarchy
yeah you know and then starts to create
this conversation between two sides yeah
let's go to my studio i sat on the team
and explained our idea of getting to
South Africans on either side of the
spectrum when a police officer and one a
criminal we need a policeman yes a
policeman dad my sister's a lawyer do
you know any policemen I think I've got
one when working on a previous
documentary I had gained the respect of
Turner a gang leader in Cape Town by
teaching him how to play the piano and
getting him a tattoo me
I just want to interject you I do not
agree nor disagree with any individual a
showcase on my channel like any foam
it's all up for audience interpretation
my job is to merely pose the imagery and
tell the story through my lens the idea
here is to get them onto a boat and to
go
multiple miles offshore to commit five
petty crimes in international waters
before posing our important question you
see both Louie and Turner lived in the
height of apartheid fellow South African
Trevor Noah says in his early years in
South Africa that he was literally born
a crime which is essentially true of
Turner - Turner's crimes were an act
against the oppressive regime which he
was later expanded off if anyone can
answer the question about celebrating
your differences it would be these two I
already noticed a complete change in
both Louie and Turner
laughing together and just celebrating
their differences if you will whatever
it was and for however short a time it
may be a wall disappeared between the
two so to speak we then walked along the
dark and Tristan gotta ask his question
is it possible to celebrate our
differences in South Africa white people
I understand even every now told to hate
people tight people are currently the
evil what is really maybe not so bad now
you must be crazy other words like a
dude [ __ ] that is a criminal right
give him a chance
you know what
I didn't age if they were displaced and
that this Brisbane is me I screwed
who works with you to stay out of Game
Jam that will you go people will like
each other if you Google just like each
other but also good why I find one thing
if you don't talk nobody won't
understand you that's the most important
thing I think what I've learned today
most importantly is like seeing like how
we broke the dance such a basic like
playful level where it's like hey we're
not trying to say that everybody should
be friends we're not trying to say that
the whole world should get on and live
in this area fairy mindset at all it's
rather that people probably don't take
the opportunity to meet other people
based on preconceived ideas without
actually engaging and going like hi
yes Samia - I'm sensing you know for me
thank you for your seed because I got to
know
from this and I'm going to come back
over to South Africa and creating the
user opportunities to spread this this
message which is awesome
and don't forget your awesome proof and
I'll see you next week way perfect I
just want to say a huge thank you to my
sponsors vnh for the awesome gear
epidemic sound for the insane library of
music and skill share the online
learning platform for creators there's a
link in the description to get a two
month free trial with Skillshare so
check it out make sure to subscribe and
watch out for next week's episode where
we are tackling monsoon season in Mumbai
India